now three weeks ago we showed you how
the Democrat infotainment complex
launched beta or Roark into the
political stratosphere complete with a
glossy beautiful Vanity Fair feature the
former Texas congressman was a hot
political pinup with an impressive
fundraising haul he went from Texas
Senate race loser to a modern-day
matinee idol complete with legions of
adoring female fans but soon it seemed
like a sleight of hand all of it or
maybe of just hands flailing then came
the gaffes about being a part-time
parent and his apology for his privilege
and didn't you just start feeling
exhausted by it all I think in this
weird new cycle bado
already kind of seems like yesterday's
news meanwhile the newest darling of
journalists Hollywood errs and Metro
Lefty's is the mayor of South Bend
Indiana meet 37 year old Pete but a
judge Navy reservist Harvard grad Rhodes
scholar and he's a married gay man which
if he won the presidency would be a
presidential first and remember America
likes first the coastal elites I don't
think they've ever loved a Midwestern ER
as much as they loved Pete he's a
charmer he is disarmingly charming he is
he's got this like you know like almost
like a like an innocence about him but
at the same time he is an intellectual
Oh Anna he's beyond intellectual he was
so insightful and I guess the good news
is that actually being insightful being
knowledgeable about the issues
and also having a good positive spirit
actually still counts for something in
politics he's versed on policy he can
talk about anything you asked him he's
so different from what we have now it's
incredible to see how quickly he's been
able to rise being the complete opposite
of what we see right now in the White
House when it comes to the way he speaks
just his calmness yet his character he
doesn't like women and yes he's humble
what's a Harvard what's the UK for
further study after that and that was
when I realized it actually really
mattered a lot to me that I was further
study mean you were ruins leftist and
never Trump errs across the land are
falling in love we just got inundated
with calls by people saying this guy is
the real thing we love mayor Pete but
pronouncing his last name that's another
issue altogether people who to judge for
example people get booed again and Budig
edge we saw Peter but tagged the mayor
of Indianapolis or South Bend Indiana
mayor Pete Budetti Pete boot and edge
edge edge it's not easy okay I think
I've made it the whole way through this
monologue without watching it once but
don't bet on me all right well mayor
Pete smartly makes light of his last
name check out the wall of his new
office we're just finding our way into
this new headquarters which is full of
space it's increasingly full of a
fantastic team there's nothing else
anybody who walks into this place is
gonna know how to say her name come on
that's cute in a Doogie Howser
claymation figure kind of way but what
do we really know about the new it boy
well as mayor of South Bend
he spent tens of millions of dollars on
infrastructure he imported a lot of lime
bikes which a lot of locals abhor and he
seems to have trouble keeping track of
the homicide numbers in his city when I
was a kid it was not unusual to have
more than 20 homicides in South Bend
last year we had nine that is obviously
too many look at your term as mayor it
had it gone
until last really she was up and down
from year to year if you look at
something like that like the homicide
rate well look but Judge is certainly
really smart he worked at McKinsey it's
a global consulting company after
finishing at Oxford now he says he's a
traditional Episcopalian whatever that
means these days and in a New York Times
column neocon moralist David Brooks in
full fanboy mode writes Buddha judge is
gay and personifies the progress made by
the LGBTQ movement but he doesn't do so
in a way that feels threatening or
transgressive to social conservatives he
has conservative Family Values it's just
that his spouse is a husband not a wife
well first of all I don't know how many
social conservatives David Brooks
actually knows or interviewed for this
column but what did you just support for
abortion on demand doesn't qualify as
they did with Obama the media is
attempting to take a novice with limited
experience and wrap him up in a warm
fuzzy personal narrative Buddha judge
mayor of South Bend Indiana
you know Chester is not only the first
openly gay presidential candidate he's
also a newlywed marrying husband chaste
and Buddha judge just last year I
married a teacher so so I married up I'm
really excited for the country to get to
know him on a much larger scale well
also with the as with Obama footage is
his parents were radicals his father
whom he describes in his memoir as a man
on the left was a Notre Dame literature
professor so that's great but according
to the Washington Examiner Joseph Buddha
jej was a committed Marxist who
affectionately embraced the Communist
Manifesto and worked to quote inject
Marxism into the wider culture Pete was
close with his father which you can
expect which will lead of course many
voters to wonder how far the apple fell
from the tree it's a question he's going
to be asked on the campaign trail but
come on why fixate on any of that does
it really matter David Brooks says he is
awash in conservative Family Values and
despite having never held statewide
office Buddha judge has something else
going for him
quote he's a progressive on policy
issues but he doesn't sound like an
angry revolutionary he is shoes grand
ideological conflict god this reads like
an old Oh to Obama that Brooks wrote but
I think like did me write the same exact
thing about Obama the aura and the
historic nature of the man is far more
important than the substance kids get
used to it but let me ignore all the
Ghazi profiles and you find Budaj edge
it's pretty much a garden-variety
leftist and he's kind of calm and
soft-spoken for sure but this is what he
supports he supports the green New Deal
a wealth tax singer payout payer health
plans amnesty for certain illegals
packing the court with more than nine
justices and then there's this would you
support getting rid of the electoral
college
absolutely it's got to go so don't be
fooled by the carefully curated public
image the guy believes in a set of
policies that would set back our
economic gains and take money out of the
pocket of people who work for government
programs that don't he would up in the
Constitution to ensure that California
New York Trump the views of Heartland
Indiana --nz every time
last August he derided President Trump
as basically a disgraced game show host
and a vice president pence he said this
a social extremist the likes of which
our country has not known in national
politics wow so much for those
conservative Family Values beyond his
Boy Scout demeanor and mayor peach dick
Budaj edge is but another creation of a
media apparatus desperate to oust Trump
same reason they built up AOC in bado to
whip up the Democrat base keep them
excited keep them engaged anything to
divert voters attention from their
growing 401ks
bigger paychecks and all that good news
that happen because of Trump's policies
oh and another thing the cool fact that
cool Pete speaks seven languages doesn't
change the fact that socialism doesn't
work in any of them and that's the angle